platesmiths this is the strength test
I'll be testing the strength and
durability of your blades on these cow
bones
Theo are you ready let's bring it on
[Music]
yeah nice man Theo
I'm noticing right here you have this
wrinkle but you don't have chips and
that tells me they your blade is not
hard enough it is hardened somewhat but
you didn't get a full transformation and
that is why I think that your blade
wrinkled but it cut good
overall
you did well
thank you
Joe
are you ready I'm nervous good
when I look at the bones I think there's
no way that my blade is going to stand
up to these things without some sort of
damage if not complete failure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
's very pretty thank you one of the
twists a little bit in my hand and I
just readjusted my grip back here I
would like to have seen this rounded off
a little bit more you didn't necessarily
cut through the bone more you smashed
through the bone your edge geometry is
very thick on the edge but overall you
did well thank you
Walter ready
see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
Walter
so you had shipping and wrinkling on the
edge the edge geometry may just be a
little bit thin and that may be where it
went wrong
I didn't really need to hear what he
said because once that blade went flying
through the air I was done so everything
after that's just uh you know that's
just talking
blade Smith's at this time there was no
need to continue with the weapons tests
Walter this was a tough Challenge and a
tougher test because your blade suffered
catastrophic weapon failure I have to
ask you to please leave the forge thank
you
in any kind of competition somebody wins
and somebody loses and you know this
time I didn't take it home my blade may
have failed in this situation but I
still feel really confident in my own
skills if I had to write a book about
this experience I would call it Man on
Fire